we stuck rigidly to this narrow strip of
safe ground
to the left and right it's littered with
mines
vadim wanted to show us where he was hit
driving his truck on this road last
month this is what's left after two
mines exploded underneath him without
his truck he can't work but it's served
as a warning to civilians who are too
scared to come here now
yamas
is the picture across slaves of ukraine
fields that should be planted with wheat
are covered in munitions and mines
landmine charity the halo trust has told
sky news ukraine is now the most lethal
environment anywhere in the world for
civilians
their deminers from the donbass region
on the front line are now clearing areas
around the capital
it's painstaking work picking through
the grass for tripwires mines and
artillery
a large number of russian shells don't
detonate and get buried in the ground
so it was locals that reported uh in
april russian vehicles were positioned
here
and russian troops positioned over there
the threats left behind in the ground
here now pose huge danger to civilians
living just a hundred meters away
many still haunted from the arrival of
russian troops in march
australia
the family were given an hour to leave
before russian soldiers took over their
house
is
foreign
each time a mine is cleared their house
shakes
people's trauma here now compounded by
the regular sound of controlled
explosions nearby
so the area of this field is 190 000
square meters
and each team on average can clear 120
square meters a day so
if we do the maths
it would take the two teams they have
currently working on this field two
years just to clear this area alone and
this is one of
so many in ukraine that's contaminated
with mines
these threats are stopping ukrainians
returning to the daily lives they had
before this war and clearing them could
take decades stanley lockwood sky news
nima corey